listo Durante los últimos cuatro años
los medios de comunicación han destacado
la faceta más radical del bolsonarismo
sin embargo la mayoría de los electores
de sonaro tienen un perfil de
conservador moderado
[Aplausos]
Nosotros siempre tuvimos en nuestra
nación presidentes corruptos y ladrones
y él arrancó este tumor maligno este
cáncer diabólico nuestro presidente
rescató todo eso el Dios dignidad a la
familia
reencontramos a Samuel en bambú un
barrio de la periferia de Río de Janeiro
ambos se sienten muy identificados con
la bandera que levanta diario bolsonaro
contra la legalización del aborto y de
las drogas y contra la llamada ideología
de género
yo estoy contra el aborto desde el
momento de la concepción de la Unión de
dos personas Aunque ocurra una fatalidad
todo es permiso de Dios
Samuel que además de agente inmobiliario
también pastor evangélico valoriza el
respeto que el mandatario muestra hacia
la religión
bolsonaro reconoce que el señor es Dios
cuando bolsonaro llega a una iglesia él
es abrazo las personas quieren abrazar a
bolsonaro y no es solo en la iglesia
evangélica él también va a las iglesias
católicas católica cuatro veces por
semana Samuel y Selma acuden a esta
iglesia evangélica para orar junto a
otros fieles en Brasil el 31% de la
población se declara evangélica cerca de
70 millones de personas
los resultados de las elecciones
demostraron que los sondeos subestimaron
la fuerza de este Movimiento Político
cada vez más politólogos reconocen que
el bolsonarismo perdurará en el tiempo
bolsonaro consiguió hacer una
conciliación entre estas fuerzas
conservadoras Hay personas con un perfil
más liberal personas de derecha con un
perfil más ligado a la agenda
conservadora en el campo social él
consiguió centralizar todos estos apoyos
el profundo rechazo de un sector de la
saciedad hacia el partido de los
trabajadores ha sido decisivo para la
consolidación del bolsonarismo